[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de vie pour
aujourd'hui je le grand plaisir de
rencontrer Émilie maison d'oeuvre sur
son lieu de travail savoir le musée
Lambinet 56 boulevard de la reine à
Versailles
Emily maison neuve bonjour Véronique
merci de nous recevoir en ces lieux
magnifiques vous êtes alors vous êtes
plusieurs choses vous êtes directrice du
musée lobinet directrice de l'espace
richo et directrice du carré à la farine
et conservateur du patrimoine exactement
tout ça
bon aujourd'hui on va surtout parler de
Lambinet est-ce que juste on peut dire
en deux trois mots quelle est l'histoire
de ce lieu c'est un hôtel particulier
c'est sa c'est un hôtel particulier donc
qui a été construit en 1752 un
entrepreneur des bâtiments du roi qui
s'appelait Joseph Barnabé Porchon
ensuite il y a une succession de
différentes familles et puis en 1852
Victor Lambinet achète particulier alors
pour le louer à d'autres habitants et
puis madame Lambinet donc qui en fait ça
belle fille va le léguer à la ville
Nathalie exactement puisqu'en fait elle
n'a plus d'enfants malheureusement son
petit garçon enfant unique et décédé à
12 ans et donc elle cherche justement à
transmettre son patrimoine que ce soit
donc les œuvres et le bâtiment à la
ville et on ouvre en 1932 le musée d'art
et d'histoire de la ville de Versailles
d'accord et donc eux-mêmes cette famille
Lambinet était déjà des collectionneurs
alors oui c'était des collectionneurs
parce qu'en fait le beau-père justement
Victor Lambinet était très lié à un
historien en fait de la ville qui
s'appelle charlevatel et il est possible
que justement il se soit tous les deux
un peu influencé dans leur collection
donc on avait beaucoup d'oeuvres du 18e
siècle mais aussi du 17e siècle qui ont
malheureusement été vendus en grande
partie un an après le décès de Nathalie
probablement pour des raisons fiscales
parce que les exécuteurs testamentaires
en fait avaient besoin de aussi de
revenus et donc il nous reste une
dizaine d'oeuvres de la famille
seulement oui voilà tout le reste en
fait de la collection et tissu à la fois
d'un transfert des collections
Beaux-Arts de la Bibliothèque municipale
de Versailles et puis progression de
dons de lait et d'acquisition qu'on a pu
faire au fil du temps d'accord et
justement je me demandais ce système de
dons et de l'aide il est toujours actif
ou on peut toujours actif tout à fait
encore aujourd'hui on a régulièrement
des gens qui nous contactent alors ça
peut être des versaillés des Parisiens
des personnes même étrangères qui sont
attachés à ce musée à cette ville et qui
souhaitent avoir une pérennité de leur
collection et notamment ceux qui
souhaitent avoir une pérennité de
l'ensemble de leurs collection parce que
parfois des musées peuvent être
intéressés par une partie
voilà ne soit pas séparés pour qu'on est
vraiment leur histoire aussi qu'il soit
transmise avec leurs objets
c'est vraiment notre identité alors bon
on est le covid malheureusement vous
alors vous n'avez pas chômé pendant le
covid vous en avez profité pour pour
faire plein de choses exactement donc en
fait on a fermé pendant trois ans
donc il y a eu le covid et en fait on a
profité de cette période pour réallouer
en fait une grande partie de notre
budget pour faire les travaux donc au
départ indispensable à la base oui à la
base on devait faire juste les fenêtres
de toute une façade d'accord et puis
finalement comme on a déplacé les
collections pour les mettre à l'abri
pendant le temps des travaux on a décidé
de refaire tout parcours c'est à dire
qu'une fois que les collections étaient
déplacées on voulait pas les remettre
exactement comme elles étaient
auparavant et on s'est lancé dans un
grand projet muséographique qui a
concerné les 35 salles du musée c'est
fou donc vous avez tout ré agencé
exactement voilà tout repeint on a fait
donc des nouvelles vitrines on a conçu
aussi des nouvelles des nouvelles salles
finalement avec un nouveau propos des
nouvelles salles qui n'étaient pas
ouvert nous avons exactement en fait il
y avait 35 pardon je vous ai coupé mais
35 ça paraît énorme ça paraît non c'est
beaucoup parce qu'en fait on a plus de
1000 m². donc le visiteur lorsqu'il
arrive il a quand même voilà il y a un
grand parcours à faire il y a de quoi
faire hier entre 1h et 1h30 de visite
parce qu'on bascule on part donc des
collectionneurs pour parler de
l'histoire de l'art de vivre à
Versailles histoire de Versailles voilà
il y a beaucoup de chapitres différents
dans cette dans ce parcours et donc en
fait il y a des salles qui étaient
fermées temporairement ce que c'était
justement les salles d'expulsion
temporaire on a récupéré en grande
partie pour vraiment s'étendre et mettre
en valeur nos collections permanente
d'accord donc vous avez une fiche c'est
le mot mais vous vous montrez les
oeuvres d'une façon différente alors
comment c'est agencer on a trois étages
c'est ça il y a toujours eu trois étages
il y a toujours eu trois niveaux et puis
on est resté fidèle à certaines idées
c'est à dire que le deuxième niveau
consacré à l'histoire de Versailles
c'était déjà le cas sauf que nous on a
cherché vraiment à
amener de la logique et la lisibilité au
parcours en mettant une chronologie
d'accord donc on part du 17e siècle en
fait finalement la République du château
anciennes pour lisseur de Versailles on
a peu de témoignages en fait avant
l'arrivée du château et puis on va
jusqu'aux années 60 ensuite dans les
objets d'art le fond en fait constitutif
du musée on a aussi des objets antiques
carrément donc là il y a une des salles
par exemple qui présente un cabinet de
travail et de collectionneurs à
l'intérieur de l'appartement 18e siècle
il y a des objets antiques puisqu'on
montre justement les collectionneurs
c'est ça c'était intéressé au fil de
leur voyage au moment où il y a des
fouilles
tout à fait c'est vraiment la variété de
nos collections qui est qui est exposée
et en fait on a un tiré parti de cette
variété à la fois dans les techniques et
dans la chronologie pour construire une
histoire et en 1960 qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui est apparu comme nouvel
objet par exemple dans les années 60
alors on a un tableau notamment d'une
artiste s'appelle Adrienne Jouclard qui
s'intéressait beaucoup au sport et on
termine notre parcours comme ça c'est en
fait un tableau qui représente des
patineurs sur le grand canal sauf qu'on
ne connaîtra plus parce que le
réchauffement climatique fait que on
patine aura plus sur le grand canal
d'accord j'ai compris alors après une
fois qu'on a visité ces trois niveaux
extrêmement riches est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire vous vous vos trois
pièces phares
oui je peux il y a beaucoup de il y a
beaucoup d'objets qui sont qui sont
intéressants à diversifier c'est un avis
un peu personnel exactement chacun peut
faire un peu son petit marché on va dire
de notre collection il y a notamment la
harpe de naderman qui était exposée à
l'espace très chaud alors qu'il est
exposé voilà pour une exposition qui
s'appelait trésor cachée du musée
Lambinet où on était déjà dans cette
réflexion autour notamment des objets
d'art parce que l'histoire du musée ici
était très liée à la peinture parce que
mes deux prédécesseurs étaient plutôt
spécialisés en peinture
et là on a vraiment voulu mettre en
avant les objets d'art et vous
plutôt spécialisé oui en mobilier en
architecture plus donc évidemment
naturellement je me suis plutôt
intéressée à cette partie là mais c'est
surtout que ces œuvres là étaient plutôt
des fervaloirs autrefois et pas vraiment
des œuvres d'art à part entière et on
voulait les mettre vraiment en avant
donc là harpe de naderman là le luthier
de Marie-Antoinette est vraiment exposé
très en valeur dans le salon doré elle a
bénéficié surtout d'une restauration son
mécanisme fonctionne à nouveau on peut
en jouer on en a joué lors de l'heure du
vernissage la réouverture en fait pour
la réouverture et puis on fera de temps
en temps des petits concerts voilà très
ponctuellement et l'idée c'était
vraiment ça c'est d'être dans une dans
une restauration pas seulement
esthétique mais vraiment en termes
techniques donc elle est partie en
Suisse c'est le spécialiste en fait du
luthier et puis elle nous est revenue et
on a été accompagné par une une personne
qui vraiment joue de la repentielle très
régulièrement celle qui a le droit de
jouer voilà c'est ça exactement
et alors deux autres objets alors comme
autre objet on a une peinture
œuvre d'art on a une peinture alors qui
sort souvent enfin ces deux peintures en
fait un couple de peinture qui sort
souvent en exposition c'est deux petites
peintures de Boyer un peintre du 19e
siècle qui représente donc il y a deux
petites vues c'est une scène de théâtre
dans la version plus populaire donc on
voit des gens qui ont vraiment des
expressions
très très extraverti finalement et puis
la version plus bourgeoise où il y a une
femme qui s'évanouit d'émotions devant
la pièce de théâtre qui est récupérée
par quatre hommes pas besoin d'autant de
bras mais voilà les hommes en profitent
et en fait c'est une œuvre qui vend
toute la qualité de travail de Boisy qui
est un peintre extrêmement fin dont on
peut deviner justement le dessin
préparatoire sous la peinture et c'est
voilà c'est une des œuvres les plus
appréciées d'accord et est-ce que vous
avez réussi à j'imagine que oui le
public étranger les touristes étrangers
qui comprennent l'intérêt de venir ici
alors on a fait le choix justement de
traduire nos panneaux de sel ce qui
était pas le cas avant après on n'est
pas encore dans une phase de démarche de
du tourisme étranger on veut déjà
s'intéresser au tourisme francilien
c'est à dire que les personnes qui sont
déjà allées au château qu'ils
connaissent un petit peu qui recherche
un cadre de visite aussi plus agréable
des activités plus intimistes qui
souhaitent faire des ateliers en famille
on a des ateliers
œnologiques on fait en fait des choses
un peu différentes pour un public
on va dire plus actif et surtout plus
présent sur le territoire là on a nos
visites arts et vins qui ont été
proposés différentes soirées et qui ont
rencontré un grand succès on a aussi des
visites méditation art et relaxation
donc là vous êtes dans les salles et en
fait à travers les œuvres d'art on
cherche aussi à créer un nouveau lien en
fait à jouer sur les autres sens que
seulement la vue d'accord donc en fait
l'objectif c'est de rendre ce lieu
extrêmement vivant tout à fait voilà que
les gens viennent reviennent qui se
passent vraiment des choses
même des anniversaires pour les enfants
oui on a développé les anniversaires
donc le samedi et le mercredi et ça il y
a une forte demande c'est très apprécié
combien d'enfants maximum jusqu'à 12
enfants ah quand même voilà on prend
jusqu'à 12 enfants après les âges c'est
assez varié parce qu'on prend y compris
les adolescents en fait on a des
activités en fonction des âges on va
dire que les adolescents sont plus
intéressés par les enquêtes et les plus
petits font plutôt des athlètes que vous
allez continuer les expositions
temporaires oui on a toujours un
programme assez chargé là on a une
exposition prévue à la fin de l'année
2023 autour d'un peintre de la période
de la restauration vous voyez on est au
milieu du 19e siècle qui s'appelle du
bois de draoné qui est absolument pas
connu du grand public non non pas du
tout et notre souhait c'est vraiment de
le faire redécouvrir voilà de le mettre
en avant sachant qu'il a travaillé pour
les grands cours européennes il n'a pas
la reine Victoria la du chef de Berry
voilà et actuellement il y a des une
exposition dans une salle de photos
magnifiques ils ont est prise pendant la
la prochaine mais le réaccrochage
on est très heureux de cette
collaboration en fait Céline Klein nous
a suivi pendant certains temps du
réaccrochage donc à suivez vraiment
l'équipe et ça a permis finalement de
magnifier le travail qui fait en
coulisse qui se voit jamais technique et
ça vraiment créer aussi un je pense un
esprit d'équipe et puis on est content
de voir que le public réagit bien c'est
un côté très concret très très vivant
encore une très vivante et très
esthétique aussi
elle a su capté en fait les moments on a
l'impression qu'il se passe pas grand
chose mais en réalité il y a une vraie
atmosphère et nos collègues étaient
vraiment fiers en fait d'avoir été pris
comme sujet collègues du lycée et voilà
juste pour finir parce que je sens que
c'est la fin vous êtes donc aussi
directrice de l'espace réchaud ce que
vous n'êtes pas un petit scoop pour nous
quelle est la prochaine expo
prendre des 32 combien presque 32000
visiteurs un mois et demi énorme succès
vraiment une très très belle réussite et
puis la prochaine exposition donc c'est
dans le cadre de notre partenariat avec
la médiathèque du patrimoine et de la
photographie donc une exposition à
nouveau sur de la photographie là c'est
deux photographes de pour le prix d'un
c'est André kertez et Jacques Henry
Lartigue donc ils sont deux photographes
qu'on dit humanistes avec un travail
montrant en fait l'influence de leur
voyage aux États-Unis et donc ça c'est
deux de commissaires en fait de la MPP
qui sont venus faire une sélection et
l'exposition souffrira pour la
Saint-Valentin à la mit février voilà ça
c'est un scoop ben merci beaucoup Émilie
maison neuve de venir déjà au musée long
musée et puis après évidemment à
l'espace réchaud à très bientôt j'espère
à bientôt pour une nouvelle actualité
merci merci à vous
[Musique]